what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with devil's reign yes we are
we are back with those rain by the way
uh we're gonna finish batman tomorrow so
don't worry the the batman uh the
imposter storyline don't worry we're
gonna finish that tomorrow no a lot of
you guys were freaking out because we
uploaded the video for what you would
call it and you guys were like wait a
minute uh so devil's ring right this is
amazing remember when i told you guys
about mike murdock that's probably
what's going to happen here early seems
like it's happening here so initially
coming off the heels of the last video
that we did it was basically kingpin
using the powers of the purple man on
himself to make him remember that matt
murdock is daredevil right that's one of
the things that i want to kind of
reiterate here is keep in mind
everything that's happening in devil's
reign is because of the fact that
kingpin could not remember what
daredevil's identity was but knew that
he knew at some point in time and that
because daredevil taunted him he came to
the really the realization not so much a
decision that daredevil had stripped him
of his own identity and so the results
of this is that kingpin's basically been
harboring a grudge ever since with this
information coming back now it's a blood
vendetta right it's not even just like i
need to know now it's daredevil's gotta
die right and i mean all kind of rushes
back to him and for him it's a massive
betrayal right one of the highest order
and so when he's told the thunderbolts
have basically located the children of
the purple man remember they all
basically share a portion of his power
and that if purple man absorbs the
powers of his children his powers
heighten several times over when he's
told we've located where the children
are but they've basically dominated in
an older woman and they are living
inside of a residential building the
response of kingpin is then go do it
right go grab them casualties be damned
i don't care how many people die grab
those kids and bring them in and so
switching over to the purple children of
course they're basically trying to
figure out exactly what it is they're
gonna do the goal is to freeze zebedee
kilgrave but what essentially ends up
happening is of course there's a knock
on the door when they open it it is john
walker right u.s agent there is part of
the thunderbolts there to bring them in
and when they try to use their powers of
course because there's essentially
mental blocks in place and partially
because of his willpower that he
ultimately is able to overpower their
abilities that this essentially turns
into the rest of the thunderbolts
jumping in and then electro essentially
shocking the entirety of the purple kids
and knocking them unconscious now at
that point that's when you get into the
involvement of the champions and it just
kind of makes it makes good sense right
i mean i have a hard time believing that
anybody who's reading all the comics
would support the avengers showing up
and basically pummeling the purple kids
right just beating up children no one's
really gonna be okay with that
and so essentially it's the champions
jumping in as a way to basically save
their purple children now i have to
believe that one of the things that chip
sadarsky is toying with here is the
possibility that we could actually see
the purple children stepping in and
becoming in some capacity involved with
the champions but the champions are
basically just the teenage superheroes
or the most popular teenage superheroes
in marvel comics right that you got
kamala khan you've got miles morales and
sam alexander nova and a couple others
just the young popular superheroes right
they're kind of like the cool kids table
when it comes to the superhero community
uh but basically being there and saving
them right helping to rescue the purple
children it's one of those things where
it's like we could potentially have them
there now where the rest of the team
right what's left of the avengers
essentially goes to face off against the
thunderbolts suddenly abomination
arrives on the scene now here's the
thing we never really have done a whole
lot of coverage when it comes to emil
blonsky right covering abomination and
talking about his character he's not
necessarily on par with the incredible
hulk insofar as like the incredible hulk
gets stronger the more the angrier he
gets but the abomination is no slouch
he's more than enough for everybody here
the other thing about this is that he's
basically a criminal with a badge and
because of the fact that kingpin is
approaching this from a kind of by
whatever means necessary approach it
means that that abomination has
essentially permission to kill the
superheroes if he has to and he will
that's one of the big things right
abomination would more than overpower
these superheroes and basically kill
them all and so where the purple
children are essentially captured by
abomination the the whole thing is like
we have to go right like miles morales
and all of them are like we have to
leave we can't stay here you know and
with the response of jessica jones is
like no no we can't leave the kids here
the like miles morales is like you know
i totally get it right i mean but that's
abomination right we'll save the kids at
some point in time but we can't do that
if we're dead and he will kill us so we
have to leave right now now at this
point we switch over to a combination or
i guess a conversation between mike
murdock and butch and the thing about
this is it's actually a reference to the
events from daredevil volume six annual
number one in 2020 and what it does is
it references the existence of a
nornstone now technically speaking mike
murdock kind of has the nornstone in his
possession but not necessarily the
nornstone was actually in the possession
of parker robbins of the hook and as you
guys know the hood is one of those guys
where he's just he's always had his
hands on everything he's had the casket
of ancient winners he's had a nornstone
he's had the infinity gauntlet at one
point in time the guy's had all kinds of
stuff right he's just one of these guys
where by whatever manner and whatever
means he usually just ends up doing some
crazy things
parker robbins is a really cool
character and i really hope he joins the
mcu one day like as the hood but the
nordstone as it's explained to us in
terms of its use which is seemingly
what's going to apply here from
daredevil annual that parker robbins
describes the nornstone as basically
being something that can rewrite reality
now while the nornstones have been
depicted in different ways over the
years in marvel comics in uh spider-man
or i guess symbiote spider-man
crossroads number four one of the things
that was given to us is that the
nornstones were seemingly created by the
celestials in the early days of the
universe in order to allow the
celestials to explore other realities to
basically leave the universe and explore
other universes so essentially the norn
stones were keys to the door that
allowed them to access the multiverse
whether or not that's still a part of
marvel's continuity i'm not 100 sure
because the practical use of the
nornstones has changed so much over the
years that they're not really based or
rooted in their original intention in
more recent years the norm stones have
just kind of become synonymous with the
asgardian mythos right so thor and odin
and all that kind of stuff especially
when you look at stories like thor
disassembled or thor ragnarok as you as
you know it but the thing about this is
that if this stone truly does have the
ability to rewrite reality that it was
presented or at least uh discussed by
parker robbins with mike murdock it was
what was effectively a one-off right
like a one more day kind of thing right
you can use it once but it draws too
much heat so if you use it make sure
it's a big thing right it'll just draw a
lot of attention from all the wrong
people so it almost kind of seems like
to a degree mike murdock has an ace in
the hole butch is kind of hunting for it
to a degree but again it's one of those
things where he doesn't really seem to
believe in that kind of stuff you know
and so on and so forth but regardless
you switch back over to kingpin of
course meeting with uh dr octopus and
his alternate reality variants right the
incredible hulk doctor octopus and
wolverine and and ghost rider right
those variants of him and with the power
of the purple children being sent
directly into zebedee kilgrave now the
response of of otto octavius is okay
kingpin now you have the power you need
in order to win the election and his
response is i don't care about the
election right the election isn't really
relevant to me and then he says do you
know the reason why it is that
spider-man keeps defeating you all the
time and where otto's like i don't know
he says because you think short term you
never think about the bigger picture and
this is true because what happens here
is that with otto octavius being carried
away with his own mechanisms he never
gave any thought to kingpin plotting
against him and so while he has his
variance here kingpin who's still in
possession of the purple man's power
seizes control of the variants of auto
octavius and then has them throw auto
out of a building right like out of the
building itself then he directly
instructs zebedee kilgrave who has an
inhibitor collar on so his powers can be
used they can't really run awry but in
effect it allows kingpin to basically
dominate a zebedee kilgrave or the very
least kilgrave possibly doing it of his
own accord he unleashes them on the city
and just says kill every superhero you
can find it doesn't matter who they are
kill them all every single superhero now
this brings into sharp relief the danger
of zebedee kilgrave i've been saying
this for the longest time yes kilgrave
was really really cool in jessica jones
and in fact he was the best part of that
show but the reality of zebedee kilgrave
is he's a massive threat right he is an
avengers movie threat if the mcu ever
decides to change their tune and make
another avengers film he could be a
legitimate contender because all it
would take is for him to like walk into
avengers mansion and just say everybody
kill yourselves and with the exception
of somebody like the incredible hulk who
you could actually finagle to fall under
the control of kilgrave they would all
die right that's the level of power
kilgrave has where he goes into the
avengers mansion and takes over the team
and in the movie it plays out where he
uses the avengers to conquer the world
it's not outside the realm of
possibility he is a highly slept on but
ridiculously overpowered character if
you write him the right way and put him
in the right circumstance right the guy
could easily hold a movie on his own the
other part of this is that for the
various members of the of the the purple
family as well as i guess the purple
children as well as the avengers
themselves that at the end of the day
they don't really want to see the
avengers screw up and in fact there's
one point where a discussion is had
between uh between luke cage and
daredevil uh basically with joseph one
of the purple children and what they
tell him is like the purple man is is
100 evil the only time the only reason
the purple man hasn't used his powers to
just inflict mass death and destruction
is because it just doesn't suit his
agenda but he could right he's done
nothing but destroy people's lives
that's all he does he just satisfies his
own personal gratification and cares
nothing about the people that he affects
and the result of this is that he says
the only way you're going to be able to
defeat him is to kill him you're going
to have to you're going to have to kill
a purple man of course these guys
basically being superheroes murdoch says
i totally get what you're saying but
we're not gonna kill him right he's like
that's what separates us from them we
help people we save lives but again it's
that philosophical discussion that we've
brought up time and time again what
happens when you come across someone who
can't be saved every single time they
get out they inflict mass destruction
and harm is it one of those things worse
well we just lock them in prison for the
rest of their lives is that really any
better than killing them you're
basically just i mean in some places
depending on who you talk to and what
psychological studies you read uh death
would actually be a more forgiving
punishment right you guys ever get a
chance look up the psychological studies
that deal with the idea of um of what is
a solitary confinement and how it'll
totally screw you up executing them is
preferable they're kind of coming from
this perspective with somebody like
purple man and saying no we shouldn't
kill him we should just lock him up for
the rest of his life someone argue
that's cruel and unusual punishment
right you'd be better off just killing
it but regardless it's just one of those
things where it's kind of a
philosophical debate back and forth
between whether or not it's okay to kill
a villain that refuses to be redeemed
and so ultimately what ends up happening
here is of course you basically have a
coming together of the various autos and
so on right who just basically realized
that like you know now that they're out
of the influence of the purple man the
powers wear off and that they kind of
regain their normal selves and they're
there just in time to face off against
the avengers who of course jump in and
so now it's essentially all the forces
of kingpin versus all the forces of the
avengers which leads to a mighty fight
right like a mini civil war conflict but
a really cool conflict nonetheless right
it's it's just it's really really
awesome because what you end up getting
is spider-man says sorry auto as usual
you don't rate very high on my list of
priorities unless you've seen a certain
purple man running around we'd love to
talk to him and this voice seemingly
comes out of nowhere and says of course
as long as you don't mind it being a
group conversation and this is what
makes things ridiculously difficult for
the avengers and it's one of the things
that makes kilgrave so cool he sees
control of the city of new york like
ultimately they're like he's got
everybody right like all these innocent
people just all these people are here
and they're all descending on the
avengers what do you do here right
because each one of these people
controlled by the purple man will under
the influence of the purple man fight to
the death in order to keep him alive so
how do you defeat the purple man without
harming any innocent civilians i don't
know the answer to that question because
what we end up doing is switching over
to mike murdock that once he seems to
get into his place that or at least
maybe matt's place that what this is is
of course the whole the whole thing
being torn apart he ends up calling
butch believing butch is looking for the
nornstone that allows to rebound reality
and all that kind of stuff but when that
happens he's met by the arrival of
kingpin now remember mike murdock is the
twin brother of matt murdock who was
basically created into existence
accidentally by an inhuman that could
bring to life anything they read and
because mike was an identity that matt
had used at one point in time mike was
accidentally brought into existence by
that guy's ability to rewrite reality
the problem is kingpin doesn't know this
kingpin looks at mike murdock and
believes he's mad now part of this could
also be because kingpin is just
absolutely incensed like if he was more
logical and more reasonable he'd be able
to understand what's actually going on
here in this situation but the truth
about it is that he doesn't right he
doesn't he's just he's so pissed off
that at the end of the day he sees
nothing but absolute hatred and vitriol
for matt murdock that when he looks at
mike he sees matt now one of the things
that we said at the beginning of this
story we were kind of explaining the
nature of mike murdock is that he'd been
around for a little while but most
likely what would happen is that things
would go in a direction to where marvel
would basically write him out and that's
like that's exactly what looks like it
happens here that literally because
what's going on because he believes it's
matt he takes all his anger out on mike
believing uh that he's basically been
betrayed just screaming at him like no
more right like no more stuff and just
basically he seemingly beats him to
death when somebody walks in and sees
him doing it and he simply just says no
more right kingpin loses his mind and
beats who he believes to be daredevil to
death with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end i gotta
say devil's reign is proving to be
ridiculously good and i'm so excited to
see what direction it goes in but thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace